(bright upbeat music)
(birds cawing)
I believe that the number one motivator for a human being
is the avoidance of discomfort.
You wake up in the morning
with the greatest intentions to exercise
or work on that book you're writing,
and before you know it, you're instead making coffee
and reading the news and checking Instagram,
that's your brain avoiding the uncomfortable work.
You've gotta recognize the resistance you're gonna face
consciously and subconsciously,
and then you've gotta commit to just bite-size action
and it's gotta be consistent
and you broadcast to everybody, that this is who you are
and this is your new plan
and you say it over and over and over, you have a chance.
Hey, everybody, welcome to the podcast
and welcome to 2022.
To usher in the new year correct,
today, I'm joined by my buddy, Joe De Sena.
Joe's the founder and CEO of Spartan Race
and he's returning to the show
for a bit of a boot in the rear,
to shake the cobwebs loose and jump start those resolutions.
Joe last graced the studio
a little over a year ago in December of 2020
and that episode which went deep into his
absolutely fascinating backstory was a hit,
so please check it out if you missed it,
and so, in the spirited annual tradition that we have here
to launch the new year with the mindset tools
and the motivation that you need
to embrace your new year ambitions properly,
I thought it fit, quite literally, to have Joe drop by
for a more focused discourse on just that.
Joe's got a new book out,
it's called "10 Rules For Resilience"
and it's essentially a guide for you,
as well as for your young ones and your families
to develop what he calls, true resilience.
What is true resilience?
Well, we talk about that and we also talk about
how and why cultivating resilience, as well as its siblings,
things like discipline and courage,
can and should be built into parenting.
We also discussed the importance of personal values
in adhering to your goals,
how to navigate failure, super important topic
and many other subjects.
Joe is a character, he's a force of nature,
certainly a talented motivator, that's for sure,
maybe even a bit of a lunatic,
but I love him so hit that Subscribe button
and let's welcome 2022 with the singular, Mr. Joe De Sena.
Well good to see you man, I think
it's been a little over a year since I saw you last,
lots has happened, we got a lot of stuff to talk about.
Yeah, on the way in, the pandemic, right,
and the way out I come to LA, thanks for having me,
I love the new space.
Yeah, I appreciate that
and you've been all over the place,
weren't you just, you were just in Abu Dhabi, right,
for the World Championships?
I don't know if I told you this but,
and I don't remember exactly when I was here last,
but I never stopped traveling even with all the bans
and everything that we were told not to go anywhere,
I went everywhere,
and I don't know if people listening will say,
"Oh, that guy's so irresponsible,"
but like it was awesome because
and I'm so pissed that I didn't film it,
because airports were completely empty like Armageddon,
I was in Rome at the Coliseum, I was the only person,
the only person there,
it was unbelievable traveling around the world
and I just capped it off with a trip to Abu Dhabi,
we're right in the middle
of what they call the Empty Quarter,
which is this massive desert,
the the kind that you would envision if you and I
were in "Lawrence of Arabia", right, that old movie,
camels, falcons, like in the middle of nowhere
and we put on a race, it was unbelievable.
I was out in the desert, I took my shoes off
'cause I couldn't walk on my shoes
and it was like I had to pinch myself,
I can't believe I'm out in the middle of the desert,
like remember in the cartoons where you'd say,
"Gee, I wonder if I could make it without water,
is that an oasis, am I just, you know,
is my mind tricking me and is that really water?"
It was like that.
Wow.
It was unbelievable.
And symbolically just, the message is Spartan is back,
I mean, it's been rough
for you guys having all your races canceled,
500 employees having to weather all of that.
If you,
you couldn't make it up.
I mean, we were on top of the world,
we bought out our competitor right before the pandemic,
finally after 15 years of hell,
profitable, had some cash in the bank and then this hit and
I had a shutdown of 45 countries,
had a furlough of 400 people,
and I'm still feeling the pain,
I'm reeling from the pain still today,
there's nothing, the government's done a lot for us
but they can't do enough.
Yeah, I mean, I'm just looking at it thinking
how did you even keep it together without going bankrupt?
It's pretty hard.
(laughs) It's been, I almost broke down
and started crying there for a second,
it's been...
But it's like all everything
I mean, we're here, the occasion for the podcast
is this new book that you wrote,
"10 Rules For Resilience" like,
your lifetime of building up this reservoir of resilience
and all of these tools that are
lifted from your many experiences and adventures
are now being called and you're being tested
at the ultimate level.
I was pressure tested for sure,
the team was pressure tested,
we lost some good people just because,
I'm sure people are like, are these guys gonna make it
or not make it?
And I've probably been,
there's probably five moments in the last 18 months
where it was like touch and go,
it was like a couple more days,
we're gonna have to just pull the rip cord
and then miraculously, there's a PPP loan
or there's another government loan
or you're gonna love this,
I became friends, he's gonna kill me for telling you,
I became friends with the owner of Saks Fifth Avenue
and the reason I became friends with him
is we randomly met through a third party
as you meet most friends,
and we were in Colorado skiing and
he goes, "I wake up really," I go, "I wake up really early,"
I'm sure you wake up really early,
"I workout, what do you do?"
Or whatever, he gets business done.
(laughs) Yeah.
And (laughs).
Like your Gaydar for the other guy
that like lives your lifestyle.
Yeah and so I go,
I go, you know, I got this rusty chain, this 83 pound chain
that I usually drag around in the mornings,
which I brought with me to Colorado,
I go, I'll swing by your house early in the morning,
I'll drag the chain over, it looks like,
on the map, looks like you're only a half mile away,
turned out he was five miles away, right,
I dragged this freaking chain
because I wanted to be on time, I'm hustling,
and we became good buddies.
Well believe it or not, Saks Fifth Avenue
has done incredibly well through the pandemic,
lots of people that have been getting government checks,
which should not be shopping at Saks,
they've been using those checks to go buy
things they shouldn't be,
and then he spun off the dot com,
there's a lot of good things happening to him
and one day, my wife's like, you gotta,
have you read the FedEx on the kitchen table?
And this is when it was
really touch and go with our business,
and I'm like, "No," I'm like, "Oh, great,
now the IRS is suing us or
who knows what I'm dealing with now?"
And I open it up and I'm like, oh,
a customer sent me a $10 check or something to say you know,
"We support you."
It was $1 million check from them.
Wow!
And it was like,
and there was a little handwritten note and he said,
he said, "Hey, I just had a really good week,
I just want you to know I love what you're doing,
use it, don't use it, stick it in a drawer for a rain a day,
I hope I didn't embarrass you,"
and so, I've had a bunch of friends
and the government and the customers and vendors,
this will blow you away 'cause you're a lawyer.
Willkie Farr, right big, am I saying it correctly?
Yeah.
Big law firm.
Willkie Farr & Gallagher,
I don't know what it's called now,
maybe it's just Willkie Farr.
Giant law firm,
they helped us get the Tough Mudder deal done
and it was a big, we have a bill with them,
and I called them like all the other vendors
and they were like, "Pay us whatever you want,
whenever you want, we're behind you."
That's very un-law firm like.
How often does that happen?
It's like, this is unbelievable.
Well, it has to be a testament
to the goodwill that you've sown over many years.
It's like, if you're someone of character
who's conducting themselves in a certain kind of,
aspirational way and you've treated people well
throughout the course of your life,
like karmically, it's not surprising,
me knowing the kind of person that you are
but also very affirming of the goodness of humanity
that people would do that.
It makes you feel good and
look, I can't say I've done everything perfectly in my life,
you can't, right?
We've made lots of mistakes
but I do the best I can
and again when we talk about the book and kids, like,
I guess you gotta be humble, you gotta have
come with your hands down, not with your hands out,
don't always be asking and
the universe somehow has kept us from failing
and now races are coming back
just in time for the Omicron.
(both laughing)
Yeah,
we're in another wave, so we'll see what happens,
it feels like everything is very tentative right now
across the board.
So much to get into with you, but before we go any further,
there's this exercise bike here that,
like a couple weeks ago, there was an email,
I can't remember, it was from somebody on your team, like
"Oh, Joe wants to send you this bike,
look out for an email and then there was another email
like we're gonna install the bike on this day
and a bunch of guys came in and installed
this stationary bike machine here and I was like,
"I don't know what this is about,
is this Joe's bike?
Does he wanna ride it during the podcast?"
There was no like background on what's happening here
but there is a bike over here,
like you care to explain?
Well, first off, I make a lot of mistakes
and one of the big mistakes I make is
I'm really quick with email,
and I'll just send an email and there's no context
and you can't figure out what's going on,
I apologize for that, but what happened was,
again it ties into this book,
this guy I gotta know, Gordon Caplan,
was tied up in that whole Varsity Blues scandal.
He was a big lawyer.
College tuition thing.
Yeah, he was a big lawyer, chairman of a law firm,
attempted to get his daughter into a school,
got caught and and lost his license
and got kicked out of his law firm
and basically hit the depths of despair.
Being from the neighborhood I'm from,
where I know lots of people that went to jail and got out
and survived, I befriended him
and I said "I could help you out,
I'll introduce you to some guys,
they'll let you know what you're in for,"
and he came out and he was very appreciative that
when a lot of people wanted to distance themselves from him,
I was actually saying, "No, wait,
I'm your friend, like don't worry, whatever you need."
It wasn't like he killed somebody,
he made a mistake like many parents made,
you could easily see, by the way,
you could easily see how it's a slippery slope,
like I wanna help my kid out,
I wanna get them into a good college and.
Before you know it.
(both laughing)
Right.
You're making up stories about
him or her being on the sailing team and you know,
all kinds of stuff, test scores.
So, he comes out...
The whole thing
was unbelievable.
Unbelievable.
Unbelievable and let's get into that,
but he comes out
and he got involved with this bike company called Carol
and I said, look, Gordon, I'm not into like,
I'm the last guy to send a bike to,
that's supposed to get you in shape with 10 minutes a day.
Like, if you told me it's a bike that you carry,
it would make sense.
(both laughing)
You don't even ride it, you carry it up a mountain
and they sent it to me and I rode it and
for anybody listening,
like, I don't wanna sound like a commercial
'cause it's just a bike,
but it's pretty cool and it's a good way for me to warm up
before I do my big workout
and if they were guiding you and I
on how to advertise for it,
I would not be the guy to say that because
their pitch is you're getting a great workout in 10 minutes,
my pitch on it would be that 10 minutes is my warm-up
and then I go do other stuff.
Right.
But they've been bugging me that like,
we wanna get to Rich Roll or whatever and I was like,
I know him but I'm busy and I just kept putting it off
and then I was like, "Oh, I'm gonna see Rich Roll,
why don't you send him a bike
and when I get there, I'll show it to him,
but then I forgot about it, I did not expect to see it.
And then you walked in and it was here.
I was like, "Please, explain why there's a bike here."
(both laughing)
Yeah, 'cause there wasn't a lot of.
Explanation.
Background or explanation.
But I appreciate it, it's cool,
I haven't given it a spin yet, but.
Give it a spin, see if you like it and if you don't,
carry it around the neighborhood.
Yeah, well, the whole subject of parents getting caught up
in the greater welfare of their children
and then sliding down a slippery slope of making some
ethically dubious decisions that get them in trouble,
is sort of apropos to the themes of the book
the "10 Rules For Resilience" which is really all about,
I mean, you've characterized it as a parenting book
and I wanna hear the back story behind that,
but it's sort of a Trojan horse
in terms of being a parenting book because,
as you know, you can't teach your children
any of the principles that you articulate in the book
if you're not living them yourself, right so,
each chapter, you have these 10 principles
and each chapter is really about how to cultivate
this in your own way, followed by sections around,
okay, here's how you now transition that into how you parent
or imbue your family with, you know, these ideas.
Yeah and the thinking is, kids watch you,
forget about listening, they're watching
and you're modeling whether you know it or not,
and so, you have to live the life you expect them to live.
My father worked really hard,
my mother worked hard around health and wellness and
you're just picking it up through osmosis, right, and so,
don't expect if you're disappointed in your child
and they're not honest or whatever the things are, well,
it's a reflection on.
You can look in the mirror.
Yeah, you gotta look in the mirror,
it's a reflection on you.
The book came about because when we had children,
my wife and I, we have four kids,
we started skiing in Vermont, that was our first sport,
and I remember my two little boys skiing with me
and we sat down for lunch and I
sought out the healthiest meal I could in a ski resort
and we sat down and we're gonna get right back out there
and the guy next to us put like two cookies on my tray
and said, "Hey, give it to the kids," and I was like
"Can I curse here?"
Yeah.
Why the fuck are you putting two cookies?
You know how hard it is for me to keep cookies
away from these kids.
Away from them.
And you just did that and then it happened
in a bank where I was trying to teach them
how to deposit $10 and how deposits work and how banks work,
the teller was giving them lollipops and
and then
in challenging them to run around the neighborhood
or one day we were carrying kettlebells for a mile,
parents, people would stop
and I remember this one instance where a lady stopped,
she screeched her car and she said to the kids, not to me,
directed right at the kids, "Are you okay?
I saw you carrying these kettlebells,
these heavy weights for the last half,
is he harming you?"
What are you talking about?
She's gonna call Child Services.
I mean that's what it came to
and then I thought, hang on a second,
it's really not her fault.
She hasn't seen a child on a sidewalk in like a decade,
right, she certainly hasn't seen one carrying a kettlebell
around the neighborhood,
they might as well have been wild animals.
So, I started messing around with this idea,
we need a book that like breaks some eggs
and is a little bold and it's gonna piss people off,
but is a little more hardcore parenting and it's not,
use all the the terms we hear like,
we're not snow blowing, right,
we're not helicopter parenting, we're like,
we're flamethrower, like I'm putting obstacles in their way.
Yeah and you've really done that
and it's impossible to read the book without reflecting,
I have four kids too
and thinking, "Yeah, I didn't do that so well."
I think on some level,
we parent either to
you know, honor the traditions of our parents
and it seems like you've taken the best
of how you were parented and tried to, you know,
imbue your parenting with that,
or we try to parent in opposition
to the way we were parented because we were traumatized
or we feel like
we were led down some dark alleys or whatever,
and I just know in my own case,
my parents were great and
they provided for me and they weren't overly rough
but there was high expectations set
and I strived very hard to meet those expectations,
but always felt like I couldn't quite get there
and I think, consciously or unconsciously,
when I had kids I thought, I don't wanna do that to them
and so, I've probably been on the spectrum of things,
softer than my parents were
for better or worse and
my kids aren't athletes, they're all artists
and luckily, they've all pretty much found
things that excite them and so, we challenge them
in that regard and push them and hold them accountable,
but they're all pursuing things that they enjoy,
but I'm not the kettlebell guy
or the guy who's getting them up at five in the morning
and making them, you know,
take cold showers and stuff like that.
And I've seen what you just described,
I remember the neighborhood I grew up in
was all organized crime,
and the next generation, I always scratched my head as a kid
and said, "Why is the next generation softer
when their dad does that for a living?"
And it was because the parents had tough upbringings
and they wanted to make it easier for the kid.
That's the dilemma of like every successful person
who pulled themselves up and
built a big life for themselves and then they have kids
and suddenly they're living in a huge house,
like Kevin Hart talks about this all the time,
like my kids are, (laughs)
I can't get them to do anything, they're hopeless, you know.
Yeah, and so,
I got a little sense of that
and I always reflect back on the movie "Rocky",
I don't know if it was "Rocky III"
where he had the kids and he had the money
and all of a sudden he became complacent
and so, that really stuck in my brain
especially with the backdrop of the neighborhood,
kids being softer, a lot softer, than the hardcore parents
and I said and my wife went along with it,
let's try to make the kids tougher because life's tough.
When my kids complain to me
like all kids do, the other day whatever,
Charlie was saying something about like, "Oh, my arm hurts,"
"Your arm hurts?"
I gotta make payroll this week.
I mean, like suck it up
and my wife will say, "Oh, you're too hard on them,"
"Too hard on them?"
I just lost my best employee, you know what I mean?
So, I don't know, I feel like we're raising adults
and wouldn't we want them to practice with us
on how hard that's gonna be
rather than when we're not around.
Yeah.
And if I fail anywhere as I listen to you,
I push the workout stuff too much.
They should be working in a hardware store
a couple days a week, they should be
doing some other, learning some other things,
doing some artwork like you said,
I'm constantly drilling the exercise
to the point where I'm afraid someday they'll be like,
"Oh, thank God he's gone,
we don't have to exercise ever again."
We can finally take a break.
Exactly.
But wait, how old are they now, they're like 16 and down?
Yeah, 16, 14, 12, 8.
Yeah.
So, my older two are a little bit older
but then we have 18 and 14, so, you know, in the zone.
In the zone, yeah.
Yeah.
And they're seeing
the benefits of the hard work, you know,
they go out and do a physical fitness test at school
and they perform really well and
hopefully they make that connection,
okay, that's 'cause dad was driving us nuts.
You gotta have a partner that goes along with it,
if my wife didn't go along, it would be really a disaster.
Right, but she didn't think you writing this book
was such a good idea.
She did not want me to write the book.
We actually we actually fought over it because
you know, there's a history in America
of folks writing parenting books and being completely wrong,
like, what the hell do we know,
we're all just trying to figure it out,
and then we have, I'm friendly with a psychologist
who was willing to put her name on the cover as well
and that gave me enough credibility
that my wife said, all right,
if there's a psychologist involved, then maybe.
You go fishing for the one.
Exactly.
Who would approve of your methods.
Yeah, well, that's what I did with.
The dark arts.
We called 983 psychologists
and then finally, Dr. Lara answered the phone
and was like, all right, well I need some extra money,
I'll do it.
Uh-huh, there you go.
Well, we have a bit of an annual tradition here on the show
where we try to
kick people off into the new year with their heads straight,
we've had a bunch of Navy Seals etc,
that serve that purpose,
and I just thought like you're the perfect person to do this
this year, you know, this moment when
we find ourselves plotting our our goals and our ambitions
for what's to come,
pledging that this year is gonna be different,
that you're not gonna give up this time,
but at the same time, I think it's important to recognize
or reconcile with the fact that like,
this year is kind of different
because we're coming out of two years of this pandemic
and we've all had our ebbs and flows and setbacks,
professionally and personally,
we've had those battles with
our mindset and our habits and our discipline
and our schedules and our ability to kind of,
deal with the Zoom culture that we're in right now,
but I sense that
a lot of people have kinda played that out,
they're like okay, I did the Netflix thing
and I walked around my house in my pajamas
for seven days straight without taking a shower,
I know what that reaps and I'm not happy
and I'm depressed and
with that, I think some people feel stuck
but also fed up enough
and the symbolic nature of like January 1st
is kinda like okay, how am I going to move forward?
How am I gonna shift this?
I don't wanna continue to live this way.
The proverbial New Year's resolution.
Yeah, I know.
Right.
Which is, you know, problematic in many ways but also
at least it creates a conversation around
the idea of personal change
and I think, we're both big believers in the fact that
people can transform and we see it all the time
and our work shares that sensibility
of trying to help people understand
that we all have it within ourselves,
to change those things that we don't like about ourselves.
Yeah, just because you've been one way for half your life
doesn't mean you have to be that way
for the rest of your life,
just because you have a thought in your mind
doesn't mean it's true,
and so, you need to start changing that narrative,
I'm obviously a big, I mean this is all I preach,
is and it doesn't matter if it's January 1st or July 2nd or,
it doesn't matter, just start.
So, here's what I believe,
I believe that the number one motivator for a human being
is the avoidance of discomfort,
and it's not just me, I've done a lot of podcasts too,
I've talked to some smart people like yourself
and we will avoid discomfort at all costs,
it kept us from freezing
for thousands of years on the planet or falling off cliffs
and we don't even know we're doing it.
You wake up in the morning
with the greatest intentions to exercise
or work on that book you're writing,
and before you know it, you're instead making coffee
and reading the news and checking Instagram,
that's your brain avoiding the uncomfortable work,
and so, the quicker you could recognize that that,
it's me, I didn't get my 300 burpees done this morning,
I got 180.
I've somehow found 22 phone calls to make
that I could have lived without,
because I just didn't wanna get the 300 done, right,
and so, you've gotta recognize that
that's what's driving you consciously and subconsciously,
and then you gotta commit to just bite-size action
and it's gotta be consistent, a lot of people,
I'm gonna go in the gym, I'm gonna do all these things
and then, you know, life does get in the way
and you don't get that three-hour workout
or whatever that thing is you're committed to,
and then all of a sudden you fall off completely
and you don't do it, but if you commit to,
I'm just gonna walk a mile a day or
I'm just gonna take stairs instead,
whatever the thing is, I'm gonna have,
I'm just gonna have a salad with every meal.
I'm still gonna eat cake, I'm still gonna eat meat,
but I'm gonna have a salad, like if it's bite size
and you broadcast to everybody
that this is who you are and this is your new plan
and you say it over and over and over,
and you recognize the resistance you're
gonna face consciously and subconsciously, you have a chance
and then the last thing I would add
is you gotta have a date on the calendar,
you gotta have something pending that's coming up, right?
That's a little scary.
It's a little scary,
but you gotta have a date on the calendar.
We have a wedding business in Vermont, my wife and I
and we've been doing it for 22 years
and I get to meet the couples a year before they get married
and they're one size and shape
when they show up to book the place
and they're a different size and shape
when they show up to get married
and so, they have a date on the calendar, right,
and I started toying with it,
wait a minute, when I have these races
on my own personal calendar, I wake up earlier,
I go to bed earlier, I don't eat as many cookies.
So, you gotta have, just
very few of us do it without a date on the calendar.
Right, so, it's this tension between
the date on the calendar, which is the big scary thing
and the daily bite-sized things that are very digestible
and I think people
lose enthusiasm around the bite size thing
because it's not sexy,
but that truly is the way that you move everything, right,
it's just adherence to that small thing
that you can do every single day
and when you do it, even after a few times,
you become much more emotionally engaged
and connected to that thing
because you've built, there's something
ephemeral but also powerful about momentum
that doesn't make sense but
once you've created a little bit of momentum,
a lot of that resistance starts to fade.
Yeah, the momentum,
the fact that it's a ritual that you get to break,
a streak that you get, you know, hey,
60 days in a row I've walked a mile
and I have lots of people telling me they've done it and so
yeah, you just have to start,
you just have to start and
consistency is more important than
I would say quality, really, yeah quantity
it's just consistency.
Why do you think most people, the vast majority of people
fall off their New Year's resolutions?
Well, I think they bite off more than they can chew,
and they're like, I'm gonna go to the gym every single day
and workout for an hour and a half or I'm gonna,
whatever the thing is, it's just too big
and it's too big of a change from where they were, so,
look, I've talked to lots of Olympians
as I'm sure you have, lots of successful businessmen
and there's one thing in common that I find
and it's something I employ which is,
I don't feel like doing this, right,
I know I said I'll walk, I just don't feel like doing it,
I don't feel like doing my 300 burpees,
I'll tell you what, Joe, we're just gonna do 10 today,
we could live with 10,
and then you do 10, you're like I'll get 20 done
right, at 20 I can get 30 done,
I'm embarrassed if I don't get 40 done
and cyclists that have five hours to ride every single day
tell me, they're just gonna do 30 minutes
'cause they don't feel like doing it now,
I was with two world champion rowers in Abu Dhabi
two weeks ago, same thing,
they gotta go out there seven hours a day,
all right, today we're just doing an hour,
an hour turns into two and turns it, right, so, like.
That first bit is always the hardest part.
Just get going.
Getting out the door.
And so, don't bite off too much,
tell yourself, lie to yourself and say
we're just gonna do a little bit today
because a little bit is better than nothing
and stop with the B.S. of I don't have the time,
are you kidding me?
Just track how much time you spend doing nothing.
We all do so much nothing, right?
Well, we also delude ourselves around that too,
we think we don't have time and we think we're busy
and we're productive throughout the day,
but I've engaged in this exercise where
if you have a practice,
carry a journal around with you
and write down what you're doing every 15 minutes,
it would blow your mind.
It blows your mind, how much time you just waste
doing things that don't move the needle, right, so.
It's not a time thing, it's a priority thing.
It's a priority thing,
so, exercise has to be first and foremost
because if you're not taking care of yourself,
you can't take care of anybody else.
What's the point of doing all this work
and trying to accumulate all this money or doing
if you're not healthy,
so, it's gotta be first and foremost,
first thing in the morning, no matter what's going on,
I have to do my workout, I'm sure you're the same way,
I have to do something.
I also think
there's
a problem
with our instant gratification culture, right, so
yeah, you're enthusiastic about your goal
but when you're not seeing immediate results
or the results that you want in a dramatic fashion
in a pretty short period of time,
people lose enthusiasm for it.
You mean 100 pounds overweight,
I don't have a six-pack in two weeks?
Right, yeah, that thing
and I think we overestimate
what we can accomplish in short periods of time
and we're not wired
to think more long-term about these things,
but I think one thing that you've done very well is
you need all of those things
to create that level of engagement, but at some point,
you develop the habit and the practice
to be doing them just because
this is who I am and this is what I do,
it's not necessarily tied to a date on the calendar,
it just becomes your value set and who you are.
Well, there's no doubt about it that you have to
put on a board, put on a bunch of Post-its around the house
if they still even sell Post-its, I don't know,
and what are your values?
What are the things you stand for?
What do you wanna stand for
and then make sure that your actions every day
align with that.
Two days ago, I was in Florida,
I went in Lake Nona,
attempting to be this health and wellness,
I have to get you down there,
this health and wellness capital of the country
and they have a...
What part of Florida?
Orlando, funny enough, right by the airport,
17,000 acres that they got
Deepak Chopra there, they brought in
a bunch of companies all around health and wellness.
So, I'm down there and
they wanna test me in their performance center
and I'm not like, it's three in the afternoon,
I just had lunch,
I already did a two-hour workout in the morning,
I don't feel like doing this thing
and it's the first time ever that I've like pushed back and
I could see everybody's face like,
this is Joe, the Spartan guy, he doesn't want,
I was like fuck it, all right, I'm doing it
and I did it
because of exactly what you said like,
that's who I am, I'm supposed to do
the hard things when I don't want to,
I ask the whole world to do the hard things
when they don't want to.
So, I got on the bike and I did the 40-minute test,
they checked you know lactate threshold or whatever
and I felt better.
There's no, the only bad workout is the one you don't do.
I've never not felt better at the end of it, never.
I've never not felt better at the end of a cold shower,
it sucks getting in,
but getting out, you feel alive.
You do that every day still?
Every day and it sucks.
(laughs) It doesn't get easier.
Never gets better.
Yeah.
Sucks.
Do you do the ice baths and all of that,
the plunging?
when there's a place for me to plunge into, yeah.
One of the things that you talk about in the book
is this different, I mean, it's all about resilience
so we should define resilience but
you define resilience in contrast to this idea of like
true resilience, so,
maybe define resilience
and why true resilience is something a little bit different.
Yeah, I mean a lot of people talk about
and I've evolved actually, since I've written the book
with this concept, which a lot of people
just think it's just that ability to stand there
and take the beating, right,
and be able to bounce back,
but I also think it's the ability to pivot
and move, because we could get so stuck in our ways,
I've had many failures in my life because of that,
like you're just so obstinate that I'm not gonna move,
that you've gotta be open-minded enough
to make a left or make a right
or do something slightly different
because whatever you were doing is not working.
However, it's really important that you keep in mind
your mind will play tricks on you,
you know this as good as anybody else,
I've had
10,000 conversations with individuals doing our races,
one-on-one and
they pivot, quit,
at times when they didn't need to,
because their mind was playing a trick on them
and I like to say,
if you and I were climbing Mount Everest, let's say,
and my value system was to be
the greatest climber that ever lived
and this was my window when you and I were
100 feet from the summit,
this was my window to set the world record,
you, your value system was to be
the greatest family man that ever lived,
have the greatest podcast ever and
we're both about to go and the weather gets bad,
I probably should go for it no matter how I'm feeling
because I got a different value system,
you probably should turn around and go down.
You wanna be the best, right, so, you gotta have
enough resilience, you gotta be able to really reflect
and dive into what's going on in your head and say
am I quitting because it's just hard
or am I quitting because it aligns, or pivoting,
because it aligns with my value system,
so, it's being open-minded and true to yourself enough
to be able to answer that question correctly.
Yeah, I think that's a really important point to make
because in the context of fitness,
you have fitness fanatics who set a goal
and they become very narrowly focused on that,
but maybe they have kids or they have,
their value set is broader than just performance in that
one specific realm,
but they kind of push all their chips into that
for a short period of time
and resilience in that context means, you know,
being flexible or less rigid when,
hey, listen, you gotta go to the recital today,
like you're not gonna be able to do that workout
that's in your training program
and not like losing your mind over that.
I see a lot of that.
So, we think of resilience as like
you gotta be tough and you gotta be able to go out
when it's pouring rain and freezing,
but it works the other way same time 'cause you know,
most people are not professional athletes.
No, you used the better word than I did,
which would be, less rigid,
and I see it a lot in business, right,
I wanna hire a lot of people at the company
that really believe in the brand,
but there are some that really believe in the brand
that don't really wanna work
and that's a tough one to understand
because if they're crawling on the barbed wire
and they're running every day and,
they clearly wanna work but
that's fun in some ways, you know what I mean?
The hard work is gonna the recital maybe.
Yeah.
Or sitting down and doing the emails
and so, you do have to be
non-rigid enough to be able to
do it all, right.
Yeah.
How do you think about
rest and recovery and kind of periodizing all of this,
given the fact that we all live like busy lives
and we have multiple things competing for our attention,
I think on the surface level,
you could strike somebody as being
the guy who's like the hustle porn guy
and like, you never stop, you just keep going
until your body just completely breaks
and you got nothing left to give.
Well, I mean, again,
my ideas around this,
my intelligence around this have evolved.
(both laughing)
From the guy who like gets
50 ultras in a year and almost like blew up his marriage.
Yeah, I,
my wife is amazing that she's still with me but
I,
my statement to that
had you asked that question five years ago is,
I'll rest when I die, right,
my exit strategy is death.
Are you like, what are you like, 52 now?
52, yeah,
and
I'm tired (laughs).
But
I've lived three lives in one you know,
and so, I,
my assistant thinks I'm a lunatic
'cause if I'm coming to LA to see Rich Roll,
we could squeeze three other meetings in,
and then I could get on a red eye and go home and so,
rest has never been a priority,
I sleep when I can, not when I have to,
so, if I'm on a plane, pass out, wherever I am,
I'm just falling asleep to catch up
and then just get recharged.
People refer to me
as the guy
like, on a phone battery, that always
is really close to running out of juice
but never quite dies.
You just did like 8%
all the time.
All the time,
and then I had a Navy Seal
who is a sleep expert on the podcast recently
and he is the same way and the Navy Seals were the same way
and he tried to talk
to the folks
that are in charge of the Navy Seals
and they all laughed at him, he's like,
"I think we should have them sleep a little more,
they should take naps,"
and they laughed him out of the room, which you would get,
I would have laughed him out of the room, right.
You need eight hours, I think,
here's what I came to the conclusion, ready for this?
Your audience's gonna love this,
you and I should go on this mantra,
we, and this is from my buddy Nick Morris two days ago,
we need to set our alarm clocks
for when to go to bed, not to wake up.
That's a super interesting idea.
We have it backwards.
If you set your alarm for that time to go to bed,
you should never need to set the alarm to wake up.
Yeah and that's, I think our problem.
In the last week since I was on with the Navy Seal,
I've been in bed by no later than 9 p.m.
On my own, I was up at four and change this morning,
like no problem.
So, if it starts to bleed into 10:00, 10:30,
11:00 for some people, who knows what time for others,
it's too late.
Yeah and the thing for the younger people listening,
when you get older,
I'm waking up at 4:00 or 4:30 no matter what,
so, I better go to bed at 9:00 because I'm just,
I just wake up, I can't sleep in no matter what,
so, it's super important to me to be in bed at 9:00.
So, we should start this narrative that
everybody's got it wrong,
you gotta set your alarm clock at night.
I like that.
To go to bed
and I don't know if you believe this but I believe this,
there's really nothing good that happens after 10 p.m anyway
(both laughing)
what are you possibly doing after 10 p.m?
Yeah.
Now they have the, you could meet a girl or a guy online,
you don't even need to like go to a bar or any of that.
Sorry to interrupt the flow,
we'll be right back with more awesome,
but first, I do wanna snag a quick moment
to talk about something I care a lot about,
which is the importance of nutrition
and the thing is, most people I know
actually aspire to eat better,
to incorporate more whole plants, fruits, vegetables, seeds,
beans and legumes into their daily regimen.
Sadly however, without the proper tools and support,
very few end up sticking with it
and so, because adopting a plant-based diet
transformed my life so profoundly and because
I want everyone to experience
some version of what I've experienced,
we decided to tackle and solve this very common problem
and the solution we've devised, I'm proud to say,
is the Plant Power Meal Planner,
our affordable, all-in-one digital platform
that sets you up for nutrition excellence
by providing access to thousands of customizable,
super delicious, easy to prepare, plant-based recipes.
Everything integrates with automatic grocery delivery,
you get access to our team of amazing nutrition coaches
seven days a week and many many other amazing features.
To kickstart your health intentions this new year,
we're offering you $20 off
a one-year membership with the code
Power20 throughout the entire month of January.
Again, that's promo code Power20
for $20 off at meals.richroll.com.
All right, back to the pod.
So, let's get into these
principles for resilience, you have 10 of them, right,
and the first one is, you can't until you can,
I mean, they're all like.
Just obvious, it's obvious.
I read this book and I'm like, yeah,
I live this and I understand all of these things,
clearly many people don't and need it,
so, it's a service that you're doing this,
but they're all pretty self-evident.
Yeah, I mean, listen, we talked about it before.
My kids say it, I'm sure your kids said it
when they were growing up, I can't do that
and I just say, "You can't yet,"
right, we all can't do something yet.
Isn't it amazing, I'm sure you've studied this, where
there's a world record broken in running
or cycling or whatever and then all of a sudden,
there's 13 more people around the world
that break the same record
that couldn't be broken for 15 years.
So, it's really our minds that limit us
and the sooner we could teach children, they can't yet,
the better children we're gonna have.
We shouldn't be limiting ourselves on what's possible,
we should not put limits on things,
anything is possible.
My oldest son will say, "Does that mean I could fly, dad?"
Well, I mean, the Wright Brothers figured it out.
(both laughing)
Yeah,
get on that problem.
Maybe, you know, just 'cause no one's done it yet.
Exactly.
Who knows.
The idea of living your values is one of them as well
and you touched on that a minute ago.
I think it's
an important exercise to be
journaling or connecting with
what your values are on a regular basis,
'cause our values are shifting
depending upon what's happening,
but I think a lot of people just,
we're not in a culture that is really
encouraging us to think about that, right,
so, I think there's a lot of people who are like,
"I don't know what my values are, I wanna
provide for my family and like, you know,
I don't know, watch football on the weekend,"
like, it doesn't go much further than that,
so, how does one who's never really wrestled with this
even begin to unpack what that might mean for them?
You know, I just had somebody that read the book,
I didn't know he had bought the book for his family,
his young children,
he said, "I really love this idea of values,
my family and I sat down and we made a list
and we were shocked at our oldest son who was like nine
and what his values were,"
and so, it's really as simple and as hard
as sitting down with a piece of paper,
giving it out to your wife or your husband and the kids,
and just taking a stab at it, like,
what are the things that are important to you?
What are the things that you value?
Do you and the family wanna be incredibly healthy,
do you wanna be known as the hardest working family
on the block?
What are the things
that are gonna move the needle?
If this was 1000 years ago and you had a family crest,
what would the saying be on that crest?
You know, and so, for us,
for me, one of the big things is like
I don't care win or lose guys, but we gotta be known
as the hardest working family on the planet,
like I can't have this business out there
where I'm telling people, like, we don't quit.
Yeah, but what if your kids
have a completely different set of values
and they're like, "That's good for you
but that ain't what, the life I'm living?"
Well, I don't care who you are,
you should be a hard worker, right.
I remember my son
was skiing, we were in the ski program at Killington
'cause they grew up on a farm in Vermont,
and I go and it's nice the parents get to go in
and have lunch with their children.
So, they go ski all morning with the ski instructors,
come in have lunch
and then they go out again for the second half of the day,
and the lady says to me, "Oh, your son,
he's already in, I said, "But it's only 11:30,
I thought it was,"
"Oh, well, he was cold, he came in early,"
and I was so furious right, but I had to temper myself.
It's tough to be your kid, man, all right,
have compassion for your kids.
And I go home and I wanna...
They wanna come and
live with me for a while.
I'm gonna expand on that for a second, so,
I'm like, Jack,
and he knows, right, something's coming,
he's probably six years old at the time,
"I went out, I was really cold," I said, "You know what?
This team might not be the right team for you,
you're on my ski team now,
(both laughing)
let's go outside, let's put our skis on,
we've got a half hour before lunch, come on,"
and he puts his skis on and I proceed to penguin walk up
the mountain with him and we're walking up.
"What are we doing?"
I said, "Oh, well, my ski team, we don't take chair lifts,
you'll never be cold again,"
(laughing) and we hike up the whole mountain,
I'm like, "Isn't this great,
you never have to go on that ski team again?"
We worked so hard, he never wanted to be on my team,
my ski team.
Yeah,
he's gonna tell that story to his therapist.
(laughs) For sure, my wife says that all the time,
but I want us
to be hard workers, obviously the parents have an influence
on what the family values are,
I don't think you could take a six-year-old and expect like,
you know what I mean?
You've gotta guide that a little bit,
they don't have a prefrontal cortex yet so,
it's not like they're gonna spit out perfect values
at that point,
you gotta guide it a bit.
I think there's a practicality challenge here too,
it's one thing if you've been doing this all along
since your kids were really little
and they're like, okay,
this is what we do and this is dad's deal,
but you come in hot when your kids are like 14, 15,
they ain't having it.
That's a fair point.
There's a book everybody should read called
"The One Minute Manager",
it was written by a guy named Ken Blanchard
and one of his concepts is,
when you manage people, which is like managing children,
you have to set really tight expectations in the beginning
at the moment that person joins the organization.
You can't let them run free
and then clamp down the vice grip seven months later,
does not work, right, they're gonna lose their mind,
same with your point, you can at 14 years old,
say all right, now here's what we're gonna do,
you've gotta start laying the tracks
early on and I definitely laid tracks early on
that we work hard as a family,
we chopped wood, we hiked up the mountain.
When Charlie was four years old, I might have told you this,
when Charlie was four years old,
he was not the most ideal before Christmas, so,
everybody got presents that year
but his presents I put on top of the mountain
and so, in his little feety pajamas with snowshoes.
(Joe laughing)
Oh, my God.
We had to go.
You've gotta be kidding me.
There was a note from Santa that said, "Look, Charlie,
I'm sorry but because you didn't give a 1000%
I couldn't get the presents to the house,
they're on top of the mountain."
Get out of here, you.
Yeah. (laughs)
(laughing) Oh, my God.
So, we, this is not new,
they know what they're getting into with us,
my wife is definitely
the softer side,
now I will tell you
well, you know, we put on this Death Camp on the farm, right
and there were many kids at the Death Camp
that were saying to me, "Oh, my God,
this is so hard," I said,
"Can you imagine what it's like being my kid?
When you guys leave and you get to go home,
my kids, this is their home."
I wanna read their book
(Joe laughs)
when they're 28.
Yeah.
But...
You gotta get
values straight.
Yeah, values are, you know,
look, I completely 1000% I'm on board with that,
I mean, I think
the tricky thing that I've experienced as a parent
is
the balance between like setting the hard boundary
and what happens when that expectation isn't met,
how hard do you come down on that kid because,
especially when they're in those teenage years,
like the communication is so critical
and I don't wanna do anything that's gonna shut that down
and if I come in really hot,
I risk them just clamping down and then
they're not telling me what's going on in their life anymore
and keeping that communication open, I think is critical,
when they're trying to figure out
how to navigate
their social circles and drugs and alcohol
and the temptations that teenagers face,
like, I want them to feel like they can come and talk to me
about that stuff, but if I'm too disciplinarian,
then they're gonna,
I'm not gonna be the guy that they're gonna come to
when they need to like, clear that stuff.
Well, in our family
and I didn't go in with this plan, it just happened,
so, it's a good model to use,
my wife is the pressure relief valve
so, they'll go to my wife
and they'll open up and talk to her about anything.
There's no doubt about it
that based on my communication and our family,
they know that I'm hardcore and I have high expectations,
I've tried really hard to explain that my expectations,
I don't care if you get A pluses, I really,
by the way, they're all striving for A,
I didn't get A's, I gotta C's at school.
They're all like speak Mandarin and stuff.
They all speak Mandarin, they do extra math but
I know some people are rolling their eyes
that might be listening, it's like
again, we don't take tests in Mandarin
where my expectation, you've gotta do this or that, no,
you just gotta, it's kind of like
you gotta exercise a little bit each day,
you gotta speak another language with a teacher every day.
Well, the Mandarin thing started because
your daughter came to you and said,
I wanna learn Mandarin, right?
It was a little bit of that, it was,
we had a Kung Fu master living
(laughs) in our house which was,
it was another story.
How old were they then?
They were very young,
I saw the movie "Kill Bill" when they were young
and Uma Thurman had a Kung Fu master
and I turned to my wife and I said,
"Wouldn't it be unbelievable
if we had a Kung Fu master living on the farm?"
So, I called a friend of a friend of a friend
and I convinced a guy to come from China,
who didn't speak any English
and would train them every day in Kung Fu,
and then my daughter said, "Hey, I'd love to learn
so then it started, so."
Did you take the Kung Fu also?
I didn't.
You didn't.
I didn't, I'm a wimp.
What did they learn from that?
Discipline,
tremendous discipline and it's really,
the Kung Fu is kinda like almost gymnastics, if you will,
so, they had gymnastics class with a Mandarin-speaking
master for three or four years,
before we switched to traditional sports.
Yeah, I think from all of this,
if you could drill down on the message,
it's really like, get in the habit of doing hard things,
learn how to face your fears and walk through them,
don't be afraid when you fall down,
like failing is part of this whole thing,
get used to it, acclimate to it
and just develop that skill set
where you're used to facing obstacles
and weathering through them because life is hard
and you're gonna have to deal with that at some point
and so, if you're doing your push-ups,
figuratively and literally,
you're just in a better position
to be able to roll with whatever life throws at you
and basically, zig when everyone's zagging and
try the hard things that no one else is wanting to tackle.
So, two responses, that one you're dead on,
you just triggered a thought.
So, as the Kung Fu master was teaching my kids in the barn
every single day for four years,
my cousin lives next door to the farm
and they have their first child
and so, I said well, I'm paying for this Kung Fu master,
bring as many kids as possible,
it's good for me too because my kids wouldn't be alone.
She happened to walk in the barn one day
and the kids were crying 'cause like it's hard,
and she extracted her son from the program,
never to come back to the Kung Fu master.
Last night, I got a text from her,
he's now a high school wrestler.
He wrestled upper weight,
he pinned his kid, they're proud, like,
so, it's hard to put the kids in those situations
that are tough, but now
she's recognizing the value of doing that,
any chance I get, I've taken him into our program
and now she recognized that, her husband
was more like you,
her husband had a really tough upbringing.
I don't want, the kids should make their own decisions,
I don't wanna disrupt the possible
two-way communication between us,
if they don't wanna do Kung Fu,
let's not have them do the Kung Fu,
they don't wanna do wrestling,
(Joe exhales)
that doesn't really develop the muscle, to your point,
the muscle they're gonna need to fight through life
when 45 countries get shut down,
you furlough 400 people,
you're about to go bankrupt five times in a row during COVID
like, I thank God I had that muscle.
Yeah.
Right.
Pay now, love it later.
There's a better one,
I picked up a hitchhiker one day, he said to me,
save the fun for later.
Yeah.
(laughing) That's a great line.
My wife and everybody,
my kids, they wanna have fun,
I say, save the fun for later.
Yeah, that's one of the principles in the book, right,
basically, fun comes after the work,
do the work first then you get the fun
and I think maybe that piece is getting missed here,
you're all about the fun, you're not like, you know,
you're not "The Great Santini", I guess is what I'm saying.
Not "The Great Santini" and I,
if you watch the movie "300" and it's not unique to me,
this is 2500 years ago,
they're joking in the face of adversity
and if you go to any Spartan Race around the world,
the racers are dying out there but they're joking
and they're having fun with it,
in the middle of the desert, you know what I mean?
So, you can have,
I have fun with it, I have fun with it.
Yeah, well, that's another thing
that I think gets missed, this idea that
hard things means that you're gonna have to
be this martyr and
you're just gonna be punishing yourself but
we experience joy in doing hard things,
that's what we're wired to do,
but our society is set up to
give us a completely different message that
obviously we're realizing,
is moving away from that joyous state that we seek,
that we can feel and express even though it's hard,
we all know what it's like
in the aftermath of doing something hard
and that feeling of satisfaction and the
conviviality that you have
with the people that you've done it
and that's what we're missing, I mean that's what
Spartan really does, it serves people
in such a meaningful way for that.
Here's a question for you,
anybody listening,
do you think your children at the end of their life
would say, "Man, I wish my dad
had let me sit on the couch more, eat more cotton candy
and watch more Netflix," there's no fucking way.
What the kid's are gonna be talking about,
the grandparent at that point,
is those amazing stories where
you know, my daughter didn't have boots
and we hiked them out and they got stuck in a snowstorm,
Yeah, you tell that story in the book,
I'm like, that seems a little extreme.
That wasn't planned, but it happened.
So, but those are the stories, right,
you probably tell about yourself
those amazing stories where you fought through.
Sure, for myself but I can't say that I've like
you know, kind of, recruited my kids into that world,
like they're not interested in what I'm doing
and I've struggled to get them
interested in some aspect of the things that
get me out of bed in the morning but,
it's tough, man.
You probably started too late to your point.
Yeah.
And you were probably
overly sensitive because of the way you grew up.
My kids are great and they're all doing really well,
it's just they don't share this interest in
this kind of stuff that I do,
and then I don't need them to
and it's sort of wired that way,
like, your kids become your teachers because
you think like, oh, they're gonna be little mini me's
and they're gonna wanna do all this shit,
it doesn't work that way.
No.
And it shouldn't work that way.
And the jury's out, right,
like if you still have me once a year on your podcast,
in 10 years, we might find out that my kids are all artists
and they, right.
Or you just, you come over to my house for Christmas
and you're the Christmas gift for the kids
and you live with me and see what happens.
That's right.
I can't get them to your Vermont farm
but I can bring you to my house.
I could do that, I could come over, no problem.
Yeah.
Let's talk about failure a little bit more
and we touched on it,
we're so afraid of failing, we're afraid of
looking bad amongst our peers
and it prevents us from trying these hard things,
like we're so caught up in
our self-image that
it hamstrings us from just getting out there
and letting go of all that stuff and understanding that
developing a healthy relationship for failure
is really the only true path to success in anything.
Well, it's just part of the process, you gotta fail.
My son,
during COVID, I pushed my two boys really hard,
like beyond what we're talking about here in wrestling
'cause we had the time,
like crazy training trying to catch up
'cause of all those years doing Kung Fu,
we got behind on wrestling and
my son didn't do well at a tournament
and he was like a little depressed about it and I said well,
you only have to lose like another 700 matches
before you get good, like that's just part of the deal
and once you recognize that like,
you know, think about Edison with the light bulb,
the famous saying, right,
no, I didn't learn how to make a light bulb once,
I learned how not to make it 900 times,
and so, that's why I go back to what I said earlier
which is, if we could instill a value of hard work,
it's a given we're gonna fail,
you and I have to agree with that, right,
that's just the reality of life.
It's a given that we're gonna face hard times,
that stuff's gonna be challenging so,
if those are givens, then
we have to accept that failure is part of the process,
welcome it, talk about it to other people,
don't be embarrassed by it and use it as fuel,
use it as stepping stones to success.
I've probably failed,
God!
I've probably failed
you know, 40 times in building this business, 40 times.
Check this stat out, I didn't know,
I told you I have this TV show we're working on,
I didn't know 95% of businesses fail
in the first 15 years of existence.
95%.
Is that right?
It's unbelievable.
Yeah.
The longer you play the game, the more likely you die.
(chuckles) Right.
So, like,
you better get used to failure.
But getting used to it
is an interesting discussion.
Your co-author Dr. L, I think
she's the one who talks about this in the book,
it's really about the story that we tell ourselves
about what that failure means and that story often
depends upon or is dictated by, you know, kinda
your blueprint or your past experiences
or your presets, like, are you an optimistic person?
Are you a pessimistic person?
And people that are very defeatist about their failures
are people who are caught up in that kind of,
negative self-image narrative.
So, to reframe your relationship with failure,
it almost involves like some
reprogramming around your neuroplasticity
so that you can frame it as just, this is good,
I failed because everybody who succeeds fails
so, maybe I'm on my way to succeeding, right?
No and that's what I tried to explain to Jack my son,
like, so what you have to fail so many times to succeed
so let's look at all the winners
in life across any discipline, it doesn't matter,
sports, business, relationships,
like you gotta fail a lot
in order to succeed and once the world accepts that,
I think we'll be a better place, it won't be a dirty word.
Right.
Right?
On the subject of
wrestling,
you have two kids that wrestle or one?
Two boys.
Two that wrestle.
One of the rules in your book is, earn not given, so
if I could be so bold, I suspect that like
you're not a big fan of participation trophies, right?
No, not at all and I don't think the kids are,
I don't believe the kids are big fans of participation.
I wanted to throw this one at you for your reaction
'cause I think it's super interesting,
Jordan Burroughs, a wrestler?
I know him really well.
So, I met him recently,
I did a speaking engagement in Illinois
and gotta spend some time with him,
like what a wonderful guy like, just an amazing champion,
but he posted on
Instagram or Twitter recently, this counter argument,
I mean, Jordan, he's a five-time World Champion
ans Olympic gold medalist
and he tells this story about getting a participation trophy
in like one of his very first wrestling matches
and basically said that even though he was
like, last place or whatever,
he was, it gave him a level of enthusiasm
that kept him in it, so.
It's rare that you see somebody who's so accomplished
that would offer a counter perspective on that.
I had a very similar, the same counter perspective from
Rod Dixon, Olympian out of Australia who gave,
who said something that I didn't expect,
which is what you heard from Jordan, which was
look at a certain age Joe,
we gotta keep the kids in the game.
Mm-hmm.
And then beyond that age, the kids know it
and they know they shouldn't be earning
the trophy at that point.
I would say for wrestling,
oh, my God, it is a tough sport,
I mean, you get beat up all day in practice,
you practice to death and then you go and lose.
Like, that's just the deal for a long time.
So, anything that could just make them feel like
oh, cool, I'm gonna stay in it.
I needed that little nudge.
And one of the things
look, it doesn't have to be a participation trophy,
it could be not giving the kid that's new
a match up against
the kid that's been wrestling for three years, that's,
what you're doing is you're actually
decreasing the amount of kids that would wanna wrestle
or whatever the thing is we're talking about.
You have to toggle or calibrate the level of pressure,
and if it's too much, you're just gonna burn these kids.
You're gonna burn the kid out.
Why would the kid ever come back
if he goes in and wrestles like, I always joke
with my kids when they're about to go into a tournament,
like oh, man, I saw your competition,
they just let them out of a cage outside,
they were feeding them raw meat,
beating them.
(both laughing)
I hope you guys do well today, good luck.
Oh, my God.
Similarly, I can't imagine that you're a fan of
the four-day work week proposal that's going around.
You made like a little video about this recently.
Oh, my god, I got killed for that.
You're born out of time my friend.
I...
Here's the thing, I was in China, right,
and I'm talking as a collective here
not individually, but as a collective,
we compete with the rest of the world
whether we like it or not and
you can't compete with a four-day like,
there's just no way, I'm in China
and I'm in this office that has 1000 employees
and the guy, the owner of the company is walking me around
and I see a bunch of folks sleeping at their desk
and I'm like, "What's up with them, you let them sleep?"
I'm shocked and he goes, no those are the,
they do 20-hour days, so every,
at lunch we let them nap for 15 minutes right,
and then I see tents in the corner,
actual like north face type tents in the corner, what are,
"Oh, those are the folks that work three days in a row
we let them sleep a little bit in their tents,"
and so, again, I know folks are rolling their eyes,
they're saying, oh Joe, you're like out of touch,
baby boomer, whatever,
and all I'm saying is,
be careful what you wish for because
if you're going up against, as a country,
as a city, whatever, you're going up against a group
that's fighting for milk, you're not gonna win.
I had a 13 year old Chinese boy and his mom
show up in my office last week,
I was leaving the office and I see this boy outside
and I opened the door and "Mr. De Sana," "Yes?"
"I'm one of the Spartans from China,"
it's a true story, "I'm one of the Spartans from China,
I came with my mom," he's got the book.
Yeah.
"I read the book,
I've done 10 of the races in China,
I wanted to come meet you, you've changed my life."
There's not many American kids and their moms
jumping on planes and going to, like, you can't compete.
He came to America.
Mainly to meet you.
Yeah, unbelievable.
Wow.
So, I'm not saying I'm sp, I'm just saying like
that attitude
we are,
look, you're gonna get pissed at me,
we're fat, lazy and sick and
four-day work week, go to a two-day work week,
why four days?
The way I look at it though,
just 'cause of the way I'm wired, if I was working in
a regular job situation,
I would look at that and say,
well, that's just more time for me to workout.
No, of course, I like the workout time
but
as a collective, there's very few Rich Roles.
Right, most people don't workout,
most people can't get past January
with the New Year's resolution,
so, what are they gonna do?
They're gonna sit on the couch more,
they're gonna eat more chips and they'll watch more TV,
that's what we're gonna do,
and if you don't believe me, look at the stock prices
of Facebook, Netflix, go down the list,
they're doing pretty well
because that's all people consume.
What are we gonna do about this, Joe?
I think it's an easy solve,
you and I go to the White House,
doesn't matter who's in office,
I thought about this a lot, I think about it every day,
we put a couple of things in place, you ready?
Number one,
we have to do a mandatory draft,
there's gotta be like an 18 months, just like Israel,
military right of passage.
They don't actually have to see war,
we don't have to send them to some battlefield,
but they gotta go through hell, they gotta go through
a boot camp for 18 months and we rewire them,
we show them what they're capable of.
Number two, we gotta give credit
for people that take care of themselves
with insurance providers.
So, if you take care of yourself,
you get like really discounted insurance,
let's motivate people to get after it.
Number three, all you have to do is
tax the hell out of junk food, tax the hell out of it.
Everybody that's out there that's a freedom seeker,
I get, "Oh, Joe this is ridiculous,
government can't be overreaching,"
somehow it's okay to wear masks and get vaccinated
but it's not okay to take away Twinkies, no problem.
Well, we have to untie the subsidies that
artificially keep those products cheap.
Let's reverse it,
let's use the money from the Twinkies tax
and give to carrot growers, so now, carrots
are less expensive.
It's definitely upside down.
It's upside down.
Yeah.
And then the fourth thing is so obvious,
that I know you'd agree with, is
let's just shut the hot water off across the country,
everybody takes cold showers.
(both laughing)
So easy.
You need to start your own authoritarian regime
in you know, somewhere near China.
Make that happen.
Yeah, North Korea.
The kind of compulsory service thing, I mean, that's
you know, we live in a culture and a society
that's premised on individualism,
and there's something beautiful about that but I think,
in the pursuit of that, we lose
this respect and appreciation for
the common good
and what does it mean to be a member of the community
and I think, some level of compulsory
service would solve that, because we don't have
those rights of passage that we used to have,
we have to artificially create them
in the form of Spartan Races because
we lack that in our heritage as
something that young people do in this transition
between being children and adults.
There is, in Israel, there's a,
if you meet Israelis, there's a tremendous bond created
'cause they all go through that,
and I'm not saying Americans aren't bonded together
although we are attacking each other every chance we get
on social media and everything else,
it would be amazing, it's so simple to execute these things.
Anyway, I'm really furious about the whole thing.
Tell me about this TV show.
So, a couple of years ago right before the pandemic,
I got a call from CNBC,
I'm not supposed to talk about it, so don't tell anybody and
they love this message that you and I are both into
and said, "Could you apply it to business?"
So, I said, "Yeah."
So, just like we talk about
"10 Rules For Resilience" for families,
we do it for business, so I go in, I meet a business,
I ascertain where they are, what the issues are,
bring them back to the farm in Vermont
beat the shit out of them,
hopefully to focus on those three issues, highlight them,
and send them back
and then check in with them in three months, so
it's like a "Shark Tank"
with a little bit of survivor
and a little bit of Spartan in it, yeah.
So, how, it hasn't come out yet, though, has it?
It'll launch in February.
Uh-huh.
We're filming right now, it's been
outside of nearly going bankrupt five times with Spartan
through the pandemic,
it's been one of the hardest things to do,
we've filmed now for like 55 days.
And they all come out to the farm?
And they all come out to the farm.
You make them run up the mountain too?
Well, so, we design tasks specifically designed
to highlight that particular issue that company's having
and every company has issues.
So, companies are nervous about exposing their dirty laundry
but like, I have issues, you have issues,
like we all have issues,
and we tend to avoid dealing with those issues
because of what we said earlier,
we don't wanna be uncomfortable.
Right.
Right, so we keep doing
the things that are comfortable
and not paying attention to the things that aren't
and then you end up like Kodak.
Right, doubling down on your strengths
and not paying attention to your weaknesses
that ultimately become the undoing.
Exactly
Of the whole thing,
what's it called?
It's called "No Retreat"
because a company would normally go on a retreat
and they go to spa or whatever,
this is the furthest thing from a retreat.
(laughs) I'm sure there's some good
stories coming out of that.
It's incredible,
it's been very, very hard,
very challenging, but incredible.
What happened with the, we talked about this last time,
the documentary that you were doing with Cal Fussman?
So, that came out.
Oh, it did?
Yeah, we put that out.
I didn't even see that.
Yeah, you're out, you're in there,
I'll send you a link.
Yeah, I wanna see that,
I'll link it up in the show notes.
Yeah, so anybody that knows Cal,
Cal was one of my tougher patients, he,
amazing writer from Esquire magazine,
been around forever, knows everybody,
wanted to lose weight,
but he and I were like the odd couple,
I had him with me for about 18 months
and I would just torture him
and try to get him away from ice cream and
make him workout and he would say, "Why?
Joe, you need to relax more and smell the roses,"
and so, it was that constant tension
during the whole thing.
He's sort of comic relief too.
Yeah.
He does it with
tongue-in-cheek.
He does it tongue-in-cheek but
and seems to be okay
being in the middle.
The foil, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Are you still having people come out to the farm
to train and stuff like that?
People come out to the farm,
I would say once a week, we get a call or an email and then
let's say, there's 50 people a year that reach out,
of the 50, five actually show up,
there was a kid that showed up this summer
on a used bicycle,
he was at Babson
needed a change, bicycled
from Boston to Vermont, 300 plus miles,
lived on the farm all summer.
Wow.
Ended up winning the Death Race,
completely transformed,
he couldn't finish the kid's Death Race we did,
we put him in the kids Death Race, couldn't finish it,
came back for the adult one, licked his wounds
and ended up winning it.
Wow, is he the kid that's
in the book, you tell the story about him or the,
I think like, the mom wanted to pull him out or something?
No, I think that's a different kid, yeah.
We had a big problem with parents,
with kids texting their parents
and saying, this guy Joe is nuts,
this farm is a prison camp,
you gotta get us out of here
and there were some parents that pulled the rip cord,
that came out and parachuted their children out
and ultimately regret it, because
it wasn't that bad.
I mean carrying a rock.
Your perspective on that
is not normal.
No,
look, I could think of an instance one night
where we had the kids on the farm
and for those that don't know
'cause Rich and I just dove into it, it was
many weeks,
we had a one week course, a two-week course,
there's many weeks where I would invite friends and family,
Rich's kids, let's say would come,
billionaires kids, inner city kids,
whoever I could convince to come to the farm and
Mountain Warfare School Drill Instructor
wakes them up at five in the morning,
it's just like you would envision boot camp,
they're in cold water in the pond,
they're getting screamed at, they're getting organized,
they're learning some basic things that
everybody should know, and then
they're getting breakfast,
they're hiking up and down the mountain most of the day,
at some point we give them an hour in the river
where they get to play and
frolic around in the river,
and then back to hard work
and they go to bed at like 8 p.m every night.
Well, I would give them their phones back at night
and I didn't realize that they were texting their parents,
like, this guy is nuts,
you gotta get me out of here, prison camp and
some parents that were friends of mine
wouldn't engage with the kids.
Like one, it's hilarious to read this,
one set of parents that said,
"Oh, it sounds like a peloton class,"
(both laughing)
the kid is like, "FU, you don't even know how hard this is,
you and dad would die if you were here,"
"Oh, but you'll get a six-pack," (laughs)
"Get me out of here," "Oh, do you want us to talk to Joe?"
"Do not talk to Joe, you clearly don't know him,
he's a crazy person, if he knows that I texted you."
Those texts would be taking place
at a time at night where I might be giving them ice cream
'cause they had a great job,
they did a great job that night.
So, juxtapo, you know, I'm seeing a visual
of them having a good time
and they're texting like the sky is falling
and so, you gotta beware, right,
because kids know how to push buttons
and if we constantly rescue them from,
I didn't sign them, they didn't join the Chinese military.
Right.
Right, this is like,
come on, I'm a normal person.
Kinda.
(both laughing)
One of the things that you do with these kids
or just any of these people that have come through the farm
and I'm sure you do this out on the Spartan Race courses is
when they reach that point of saying, I'm gonna quit,
you're like, okay, just go 10 more meters,
then you can quit it's totally fine
and just get them to like,
it's back to that little digestible
step that you can take
to shake free of whatever that mindset is
that is telling you that you're done.
I learned that from a woman named Lisa Smith, years and
25 years ago,
27 years ago.
I was learning how to run these long distance runs and
I said I just wanna quit,
she was running with me and she said, well,
why don't we just run to that telephone pole,
and then you run to the next telephone pole
and before you know it, you've run to 870 telephone poles
and you got the job done,
and so, it has to be bite-sized chunks
because it's just too big for the brain,
especially a kid's brain.
Yeah, you could quit, but not until later today.
Later today, we have the quitting bus coming.
Oh, it didn't come tonight,
tomorrow you can quit, I'm sure the bus will be here.
(both laughing)
Yeah.
With all the people that have come through the farm
and all the people that you've touched through Spartan,
what do you think, like if you have to extrapolate
from that data set of human beings,
what are the themes or the commonalities or
sort of things that you see time and time again
where people are like, losing the plot
or like failing to see what's right in front of them
that could free them?
I'm in Abu Dhabi,
two weeks ago and a guy comes up, very common,
guy comes up and he, "Joe, oh, my God, I read your book,"
"Don't say anymore, come with me,"
and I go get a camera because
I've seen this play 10,000 times.
We got a little camera rolling,
somebody's holding a phone
and I said, "All right, tell me the story."
He said, "I'm from Idaho and I've never left,
I'm a farmer, farmer's son,
married my wife, high school sweetheart,"
and I look down as he's telling me
and he's missing his leg, I didn't even notice
and so, I said, "What happened to your leg?"
He said, "I got run over by a tractor.
Married my my high school sweetheart,
we're both about 100 pounds overweight,
because of that, we kept trying she couldn't have children,
her body wasn't working.
Somebody gave us the book.
Never left Idaho my life,
read the book, started doing Spartan Races,
we both lost 100 pounds, we had three children," right,
he goes,
"My third child is three and a half years old,"
and he starts tearing up
he said, "She died, she fell in a pool and she drowned."
He said, "But I have no regrets,
of course, I miss her, I have no regrets,
I did all these Spartan things, I hiked with her,
I carried her, we rode bicycles together,"
and he's all teared up as he's telling the story
and he says, "Now I'm in Abu Dhabi
'cause I never left Idaho,"
and so, that's typically,
you hear stuff like that, like,
the person developed the muscle we spoke about earlier,
they face something hard because we all face,
doesn't matter, we're all gonna face something hard,
they felt like they had a little more
strength to get through it.
There's usually a great health and wellness story,
I gave up drinking, I gave up drugs,
there's usually a love story,
I'm back with my husband, I'm back with my wife.
And I scratch my head sometimes, I'm like,
it's only an obstacle race,
but it's not, it's those obstacles,
they emulate life's challenges
and they force people to do stuff and travel to places
that they otherwise never would have and
Rich, it's different than a triathlon
and it's different than a marathon
because in a triathlon in most cases
and you could disagree with me,
we would get so caught up in that,
that you start saving four ounces on your bike seat
and you buy that special wetsuit
that's gonna take a minute off your swim time,
but that really was never what it was about.
It was about pushing yourself past perceived limits
and that doesn't exist out there in Spartan,
there's no bike seat that's gonna,
there's, you know what I mean?
It's just like.
It's just you and you.
Just you and you
and you gotta grind through and somehow
get this done.
So, for the person who's
listening to this, sitting on the couch saying,
god damn it, I just can't live this way anymore,
like, I've gotta make this change
but I don't really know where to start,
like how do you get people,
like, what's that first step to like, catapult them
out of that mindset and that paralysis?
Well, first thing is
we all have to agree
that our brains, our reptile brains
are gonna force us to avoid discomfort,
anything uncomfortable
so, we're gonna face resistance every day.
Number two, you got gotta have a date on the calendar
and I'm not selling you a race ticket,
you could email me, Joe@spartan.com,
I'll give you the race ticket, I don't care,
like, you just gotta have a date on the calendar.
It could be a 5K, it could be learning a new language,
you gotta have something hard
where there's that pay day,
and then you just gotta do it in bite-sized chunks.
You gotta do it every single day,
you gotta scream from the rooftops
to your friends and family.
Every year I put on the Death Race.
Death Race is the hardest race we have
and I've been doing it, call it 20 years and
every year like,
300 people sign up,
90 grandmothers would die
the night before the race somehow,
you know, everybody's grandmother died,
they couldn't show up
(Rich laughs)
and then when they get there,
of the remaining, call it 210 people,
105 of them quit at gear check, the first few hours
and I got so frustrated with it, I said, look,
you're not allowed to do this race
unless you get an article written in a local paper.
If you get an article written in a local paper,
I know you're serious,
and then you're on the hook
and all of a sudden,
Your whole town
knows that you're doing it.
The whole town knows you're doing it
and you're gonna finish, it has to say,
you're doing the Death Race and you're gonna finish,
and now you're gonna be held accountable
by all your friends and family and all of a sudden, Rich,
grandmothers stopped dying,
people started finishing the race,
so, you gotta scream it from the rooftops,
you gotta ask friends and family to hold you accountable
and you'll get it done and how do I,
up to 10 million people have done one of these events.
That many, wow.
10 million people.
It's a fraction when you look at 7 billion people on earth
but it's a big enough sample set that it works.
Yeah.
So, Death Race, we talked about this last time but
correct me if I'm wrong, do you change the course every time
and you don't tell people when you're starting or
they don't know what they're getting involved in,
they don't know when it's gonna end or how far it is
or any of that?
They don't know anything
and the reason is...
So, it's a total mind fuck.
Well, the reason is, this is really important is because,
here I am, I launch my races again,
we're out of the pandemic and Omnicon shows up.
(both laughing)
Omicron.
Whatever the hell it's called, right, so,
you don't know in life like what's gonna happen,
and so, why...
Life is the Death Race.
Life is a Death Race, so,
I purposely did that
because people will train and they'll be like
getting the four ounce lighter weight seat
or the better wetsuit, they can't on Death Race.
It's a control thing, you wanna be able to control
all the variables and the whole purpose of Death Race
is to say, you can't control this.
No.
What does it feel like
to be totally out of control.
Yeah, I would see videos of how the whole group,
the whole class that's coming in that year is training
and I would say, "Oh, great,
we're not doing any of that then.
(both laughing)
Right?
Yeah, if you're training for the Death Race,
don't share it on social media.
That's right.
That's a surefire way of making sure that
you're training improperly.
Exactly,
exactly.
But how many people sign up for that?
About 300, yeah.
What is your sense of,
like what COVID is doing to young people,
it's been obviously very difficult for young people, they're
having to navigate through those formative years,
like these sorts of setbacks and challenges
and you can look at it from one perspective, which is,
how terrible and how awful, but on some level,
the flip side of that is
they're being compelled to develop
resilience around certain things
that we didn't have to when we were that age
and everything was just kind of, like normal.
Well, I mean a couple thoughts I have on it,
one is I tried, like, how for our family to
just make it business as usual.
Continue to study every day, you know,
take off your pajamas in the morning,
all the stuff we used to do, we never stopped doing.
Number two, I think,
yeah, it was a challenge but
I mean, I don't know,
I think we as parents, we as adults
need more than ever
to get these kids moving and get them challenged
and sign them up for some sport, something.
Make them learn a new language,
make them read more, doesn't have to be this book,
make them read Rich's stuff, whatever,
I think the kids need to know that
yeah, school was closed and you had to do stuff on Zoom,
but like, I don't know,
I think it's our job as parents, as adults, to show them,
I always show my kids how much worse it could be.
I got a buddy, Marco,
fastest runner in the country on prosthetics,
he had both like both his legs chopped off,
that's another story would take us 20 minutes but, he
whenever the kids are complaining about anything,
let's get Marco on the phone,
how's he doing with his two prosthetics?
(Rich laughs)
You gotta do Zoom class?
That's a ninja move.
Yeah, you know.
Yeah.
I mean, I think, sure more broadly
this swath, this you know age group of young people,
they're being told that the world is a scary place
and when they go to certain places,
like their health is at risk and
what does that do to their mentality over time,
when they're being impulsed
or messaged with that constantly?
Eat more salad, that's what I tell my,
you know what I mean, like, I try to show them that
news is a business, food companies are a business,
dad used to work on Wall Street.
If Rich and I owned a food company or a news company
and we were the most altruistic people on the planet
but we had to make our quarterly numbers,
we'd figure out a way to sell more news,
we'd figured out a way to sell more product
at a cheaper price.
So, any chance I get, I try to teach them it's a business,
I'm not a conspiracy guy, I'm just a reality guy, right?
Take care of yourself,
that's the best you can do.
I get it,
what do you think is,
like, what is it that, what's your big struggle right now,
like what is the thing that you're trying to like
develop more resilience around or.
Personally?
That you're overcoming?
I mean, is it just getting over the hump
with the business of of Spartan or
you know, what is the challenge that you wanna take on
for yourself this year?
My biggest challenge right now for the business,
which is now,
I've dropped a bomb on my family,
is I can't get anybody to the office,
you know and
everybody's moved to like,
they wanna be on the coast in Maine or
wanna live in Vermont or wanna live here,
everybody's reimagine their priorities, their values and so,
maybe I'm old-fashioned,
but I want everybody in an office,
not seven days a week right, but like,
we should be able to get in the office four days a week,
we should be able to build a culture,
we should be able to collaborate,
work together, share ideas, we do put on
400 plus events when things are humming,
it is a complicated business.
Oh, but Joe,
I waste so much time driving,
I could just do it on Zoom or whatever.
I get it but then why are we pushing kids
to get back in school?
Why don't they just all do it from their computer?
Like there is value to being together so,
I'm opening an office in Florida,
it's not for tax reasons,
I'm hoping that I could get
folks together in an office
in a state where folks do still get together and
my family's moving to Florida.
Oh, wow!
And so, my wife is in Florida at this moment
decorating an apartment,
we broke the news to our kids two weeks ago,
they're moving to Florida
Wow!
And so, it's gonna be a personal challenge
and a business challenge, now the Boston office will stay,
the 20 people that are coming to do,
you know, it'll just be a smaller office,
any new hires will take place in Florida
and so, I'm gonna completely disrupt my life,
I'm gonna make it really hard on myself for the business
and that's what we're gonna do.
You're not the first,
I was just talking to some friends yesterday
who are lifelong New Yorkers and
they're getting ready to move to Florida too.
Yeah.
A lot of people.
Yeah and I, by the way, I would never move to Florida,
I was never...
It doesn't seem
like a place for you.
Not a place for me,
I would never do it,
but I was talking to a guy, you're gonna love this,
and he's got 80,000 square feet in New York
and we were on the phone three months ago
and I was like, Ryan, I'm losing my mind,
I can't get anybody to come to the office
and he showed me around his office, there was no one there
80,000 square feet.
He said, but my office
Town office or something?
Downtown.
But he goes, my big office in Indianapolis is booming,
everybody shows up to work with their lunch pals,
they've been getting, they never skipped work
and so, I flew to Indianapolis 'cause I wanted to see this.
It was like unbelievable
(Rich laughs)
and so, I started to explore
opening an office in Indianapolis and
my friend from Saks Fifth Avenue said, you're an idiot.
Wherever you open this office,
you have to move to it to get it going,
are you gonna live in Indianapolis?
And so, Florida became the better alternative.
Wow, man, that's a big shift.
Yeah.
Do you ever get the itch to race
and dip your toe back into that or is that too dangerous?
I mean, I, no, it's not dangerous,
I would love to race.
Maybe it's an excuse when I say this,
but like, once I started having kids
and I have the business,
and you and I talked about resilience before
and the definition of that,
how could I do all three?
Because racing, I was pretty on,
like, I'll see you guys later, right,
I gotta go to Switzerland to race.
That's what I meant like dangerous,
like, 'cause you'll check out.
I'll check out and,
I got a little fix of my addiction in Abu Dhabi,
I got to run around the desert, right,
I get little little quick hits going to our races,
I was in the Atacama desert last year,
I get to go to cool spots and
and without
the requirement to put in those, you know,
crazy weeks of training away from everybody.
Yeah.
Let's wrap this up with some
parting thoughts on resilience,
the importance of discipline all of these
skills, this toolbox that I think we all
need a little bit more of in our lives
as we're, you know, contemplating
manifesting finally, the shit in our lives that
we wanna see happen.
And correct me if I'm wrong,
we'll leave it with this, like,
characters in books and in movies
or even if you're listening to a podcast,
characters that have tremendous discipline and grit and like
virtue and just stand in the way of everybody
and just get the job done, those are people
we like to read about.
Those are heroes.
Those are heroes and so, why wouldn't you wanna be a hero?
And it all starts with you,
whoever you are listening to this watch, like,
be the hero and
you could do that by walking a mile a day
and eating a salad and taking a cold shower,
like it's so easy to be a hero today.
In the four-day work week world,
never been easier to stand out.
It's so easy to stand out,
so, the parting words would be just
be the hero of your story,
think about that kid I just described from Idaho,
this is so easy.
It's so easy it would be much harder
if this was The Great Depression,
World War I, World War II, there were a lot of,
there's a lot of competition.
Now the competition's a 13 year old Chinese boy
that showed up at my office.
Words to live by.
You're awesome.
Happy new year.
Happy new year, people.
Thanks buddy, I appreciate you.
The book, whether you have kids or not,
I think is an instructive road map
for all the things that we were talking about today,
it's really well rendered,
so congrats on the book, "10 Rules For Resilience",
Joe's pretty easy to find online,
sign up for a Spartan Race, get involved, get active, and
don't wait and sit around
until you have everything figured out
and all the answers to your questions,
resolved you have to just begin.
So, the best pair of running shoes
is the one that's already in your closet,
the best bike is the one collecting dust in the corner
and just get out there and start
and go on an adventure with it.
I wanna leave one more thought on that.
I was in Florida, I told you, when they did that test,
that lactate threshold test two days ago,
I had these jeans on, I'm sorry if I smell a little bit,
I had these boots on, I was not prepared
but I that's the way I operate,
like if I don't have the gear, it doesn't matter.
So, no excuses, get out there and do it and be the hero.
Right on.
See you guys.
All right, man, come back talk to me again.
Every year.
Peace.
(bright drum music)